[Music]
yep it's the stuff dreams are made of
folks Harry Styles covering Liz oh and
guess what Liz oh loves it too oh my god
[ __ ]
[Music]
on Wednesday Harry took the mic in BBC
Radio One's Live Lounge in London to
perform Liz OHS hit track juice
[Music]
I mean hashtag snack and hashtag hold a
amil blame it on the Jews of course
Harry's fans are living for it and hit
up the comment section on YouTube to
praise the former One Direction member
one band wrote quote is there anything
that Harry can't sing and another gushed
this is the best cover Harry has ever
done fight me nope no we will not fight
you because you are right and we aren't
the only ones losing our minds over the
cover Liz oh the Queen herself shared a
clip from the performance on her instace
story Wednesday writing this is so cute
Harry Styles I love you it's gonna be so
powerful the truth hurts singer also
teased fans who are seriously craving a
collab between the two tweeting quote
you know what this means right
uh yeah I'm dead deceased can't even oh
and it gets even better Harry also
gushed over Liz Oh during his interview
with the BBC saying quote I just think
she's amazing she's one of the most
exciting artists working now for sure
she's exactly what you want an artist to
be which is themselves Liz oh caught
wind of the love retweeted a gif of his
sweet words and wrote alongside it melts
of course it's been a big year for both
Harry and Liz Oh Harry is busy promoting
his new album fine line
[Music]
and Liz oh is nominated for eight yes
freakin eight Grammys this year
including song album new artist and
record damn girl
how does it feel to be getting all this
love I mean it feels really good I've
been working my ass off for a long time
everybody knows the people who know know
and right now I just feel like it's what
we deserve you know we've been killing
it and now we get to kill it on the main
stage so I'm just enjoying this weekend
because next year it's gonna be crazy
cuz I'll be nominated well safe to say
she spoke that ish into existence and
something tells me she'll be taking home
a lot of Grammy gold of course you can
count on et to bring you all the latest
news on Liz oh and Harry so make sure to
keep it locked on et until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]
[Music]